sieze history by the ball-sized medical  marijuana is already a multi-billion  dollar industry so the future is this  weed pill you're still not sure about  this look most people will tell you as  alden walked on the moon and even a  complete idiot will tell you Neil  Armstrong did it first and do you know  why he went first because he pushed Buzz  Aldrin out of the way he's history but a  ballsack I'm satisfied Harold you're  gonna fly to Mexico and deliver the  formula to the lab you tell whoever's  got you there is no deal unless they  come way down on the price what can we  call you back focus  somebody's going down  what is going on  he works for phanpy  I don't think you can survive that  gringo please ma'am you really believe  in God because I believe in God what  kind of person does not believe in  ghosts I guess I kind of do it but the  theaters March 9th  [Music]  you